bonjour à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france pour
cette édition spéciale avec un 14
juillet pas comme les autres coronavirus
oblige la fête nationale est célébrée
s'étaler dans un format plus réduit avec
un hommage national aux personnels de la
santé mobilisés pendant la crise
sanitaire
pas de troupes ni de blindés pour
descendre les champs-elysées à la place
vous le voyez ce cortège place de la
concorde avec deux mille militaires
défilé sans public elle le défilé aérien
lui est maintenu le tout fait en
présence d'emmanuel mâcon et du
gouvernement ainsi que de quelques 2500
invités ceux qui ont été en première
ligne lors de l'épidémie de corona virus
on retrouve en direct notre reporter
estelle farges
sl bonjour c'est un 14 juillet a placé
sous le signe de la reconnaissance
emmanuel macro qui est place de la
concorde en ce moment
oui exactement à doha emmanuel macron à
qui est accueilli par le général
lecointe le chef d'état major est
désarmé ils procéderont à une revue des
troupes qui devrait a débuté au niveau
du pont de la concorde alors cette
édition 2020 elle s'ouvrira avec un
hommage au général de gaulle avec ce
triple anniversaire les 130 ans de sa
naissance et 50 ans de sa mort et les 80
ans de l'appel du 18 juin à 40 et puis
elle viendra le moment doha de regarder
vers le ciel puisque la patrouille de
france survolera la capitale avec ses
célèbres fumigènes tricolore qu'ils
feront place un défilé aérien on pourra
observer dans le ciel de paris une
vingtaine a dès les quotas
d'hélicoptères et une cinquantaine
d'avions à 11h40 est les troupes
défileront à pied sur la place de la
concorde et puis la cérémonie s'achèvera
avec un hommage aux soignants c'est un
format réduit en donc d'une heure 15 au
lieu de deux heures avec 2011 2000
participants contre le double en temps
normal alors l'événement elle n'est pas
ouvert au public c'est le 2500 personnes
ont été conviées donc 1400 représentent
lé français qui ont été en première
ligne face à l'épidémie des soignants
des soignants des familles de soignants
à décéder mais aussi des pompiers ou
encore des salariés
du sinn de masques alors le l'esprit et
de ce 14 juillet 2027 une nation engagée
et unie et solidaire une édition 2020
qui est placée sous le signe de la
reconnaissance puisque cette cérémonie à
met à l'honneur la participation des
armées françaises dans la lutte contre
le coronavirus ces unités qui ont oeuvré
dans le cadre de l'opération à
résilience déclenchée le 25 mars dernier
par le chef de l'état plusieurs troupes
sont représentés aujourd'hui c'est le
cas par exemple du régiment médical de
l'armée terre souvenez-vous ce sont ces
militaires qui ont été mobilisés dans
l'ouverture de l'hôpital de campagne à
mulhouse seront représentés aussi le
deuxième régiment des dragons qui ont
assuré la désinfection par exemple des
infrastructures et des transports
militaires
hommage donc à nos militaires mais aussi
à nos personnels soignants et civils qui
ont permis de lutter contre l'épidémie
un dommage distincts je vous le disais
leur sera rendue et puis reconnaissance
enfin envers nos voisins européens
quatre pays sont symboliquement
représentée aujourd'hui l'allemand
notre riche la suisse et le luxembourg
pour les remercier d'avoir accueilli
dans leurs hôpitaux des patients
atteints du coronavirus est est-ce que
vous pouvez nous aider tailler un petit
peu plus cette cérémonie exceptionnelle
et inédite le programme comment est-ce
que cela va se dérouler cette matinée
[Musique]
alors je vous le disais un manuel macron
à qui a été accueilli par le général
lecointe le chef d'état-major des armées
ils procéderont ensuite à une revue des
troupes une revue des troupes qui va
débuter au niveau du pont de la concorde
ensuite on ensuite sous cette cérémonie
et s'ouvrira avec un hommage au général
de gaulle avec ce triple anniversaire
qui marque les 130 ans de sa naissance
les 50 ans de sa mort et les à 80 ans de
l'appel du 18 juin 40 et puis ensuite la
patrouille de france survolera la
capitale avec les fumigènes et puis on
pourra suivre ensuite un défilé aérien
on pourra observer dans le ciel de paris
une vingtaine d'hélicoptères
cinquantaine d'avions à 11h40 enfin est
les troupes défileront à pied sur la
place de la concorde et puis elle la
cérémonie elle s'achèvera par un hommage
aux soignants je vous le disais c'est un
format réduit un hub pour avec une
cérémonie à qui devrait durer en tout
1h15 contre eux 2 heures en temps normal
merci beaucoup et steph h pour toutes
ces précisions
[Musique]
macway 104
on va tout de suite continué à parler de
ce 14 juillet exceptionnel hors norme
avec notre invité en direct
enrique casalino chef du service des
urgences de l'hôpital bichat à paris
monsieur casalino bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
un hommage symbolique au personnel de la
santé à leur mobilisation durant la
crise sanitaire
est ce que c'est important selon vous
cette reconnaissance de l'état c'est un
signe important il est muté signe de la
population civile directement pendant la
période
c'est un signe de reconnaissance de
l'état et bien sûr je suis certain que
chaque soignant peut être fier
aujourd'hui de la mission qu'ils avaient
de l'ami et du travail qu'il a accompli
je pense néanmoins que la partie la plus
importante reste
quel va être l'impact de toute cette
crise sur le monde de la santé sur les
nouvelles organisations sur les
nouvelles perspectives de carrière pour
chacun des soignants on a créé le
secteur de la santé nous attendions
beaucoup
j'espère que ça va pas se résumer à 180
euros par mois et que ce sera quelque
chose de beaucoup plus ambitieux et de
beaucoup plus
précis nous attendons de voir dans le
détail la traduction opérationnelle de
toutes les mesures qui ont été décidées
vous restez avec nous là pour l'instant
c'est la marseillaise que l'on entend on
va vous reprendre dans quelques instants
pour continuer notre discussion
[Musique]
c'est la revue de la garde républicaine
chef de l'état qui est place de la
concorde pour ce 14 juillet exceptionnel
son défilé militaire je vous le rappelle
[Musique]
à
une cérémonie qui pour la première fois
n'est pas ouverte au public seuls 2000
spectateurs sont autorisés à se trouver
place de la concorde 2400 soignant ainsi
que des représentants de la société
civile certains corps de métiers qui ont
été en première ligne pendant cette
crise sanitaire du corona virus
seul le défilé aérien sera maintenu dans
son intégralité 1 ce matin
[Musique]
en
bon
[Musique]
enrique casavino vous êtes toujours en
direct avec avec nous on parlait
justement de cet hommage national qui
est rendu aujourd'hui au personnel
soignant à tous ceux qui ont fait face à
cette crise du coronavirus alors
certaines blouse blanche voit cet
hommage comme une provocation en face
aux revendications d'ordre salarial et
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
portait depuis des années qu en pensez
vous je pense comme d'habitude en france
il y à une minorité agissante qui peut
revendiquer un certain nombre de choses
et ça me semble légitime qu'il puisse
contester une cérémonie comme celle ci à
côté de ça je rappelle quand même que le
défilé du 14 juillet c'est l'union de la
nation et de son armée que lors de cette
cérémonie les une reconnaissance non
seulement encore de santé mais à tous
les métiers qui ont été en première
ligne qui ont continué à travailler et
assurer leur mission pendant la période
de confinement ça paraît important ça
une valeur symbolique mais les valeurs
symboliques doivent rester uniquement
symbolique et je pense que chacun
maintenant à temps que derrière les
pales les paroles il y est quand même
des actions des décisions fortes
nous avons un système de santé en france
très performant exceptionnelle mais qui
nécessite une évolution qui nécessitent
relevé un certain nombre de défis
cette crise a rappelé qu'il est
important d'avoir une plus grande
flexibilité une plus grande adaptabilité
une plus grande solidarité entre tous
les acteurs du système de santé et c'est
ça le véritable défi aujourd'hui il y a
bien sûr un certain nombre de
revendications salariales de
d'attractivité salariale et un certain
nombre de revendications sur les
carrières les équilibres des
représentations au sein de l'institution
et dans les instances décisionnelles
bien sûr que c'est important tout cela
et c'est là où nous attendons le
gouvernement qu'il apporte des réponses
le ségur de la santé a été une grande
opération de consensus
avec des représentations de toutes les
instances et de toutes les corporations
de la santé en france
maintenant c'est à l'état d'assumer sa
responsabilité de prendre des décisions
et de dire quel est l'avenir et dans
quel sens il veut faire évoluer le
système de santé
et c'est là où il ya le véritable défi
ce ne sont pas les 180 euros qui ont été
données à des soignants en plus c'est
pas très clair comment ça va être
appliquée c'est vraiment important
aujourd'hui d'avoir une reconnaissance
pour tous ceux qui ont été en première
ligne
ça passe bien sûr pour une question
salariale mais c'est beaucoup
immensément plus complexe que ça alors
justement pour revenir au secteur de la
santé on voit bien que le plan ne fait
pas l'unanimité il a été approuvé par
plusieurs syndicats d'autres appellent à
des manifestations aujourd'hui
concrètement qu'est ce qui manque à ce
plan pour qu'il soit puisse satisfaire
tout le monde
le problème à l'hôpital aujourd'hui et
le problème dans le monde de la santé
oms général je ne peux pas dire que le
système de la santé se résume l hôpital
ce n'est pas vrai l'hôpital est un des
acteurs c'est un acteur important pour
des situations complexes de santé mais
il y en a d'autres acteurs dans le monde
hospitalier
nous devons améliorer dans le monde de
la santé pardon nous demande devons
améliorer et optimiser nos interactions
dans l'intérêt des patients et ça c'est
un site quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
pour un problème nous avons un système
de financement horriblement complexe
nous avons un système ou de gestion et
de décision trop complexe et trop lent
nous avons un système de santé dans
lequel il y à des oppositions et des
corporatismes et nous devons revenir à
la valeur nous devons tout faire dans
l'intérêt des patients nous devons tout
faire pour garantir les conditions de
travail de nos équipes et leur sécurité
et si on se repose sur ses valeurs
nous sommes capables de construire un
système de santé moderne
vraiment performant qui réponde aux
véritables défis de santé de notre
population et qui soit capable de
garantir à chaque français non seulement
l'accès aux soins mais qui soit capable
de lui car on dit que les meilleurs
soins dans les meilleures conditions en
permanence partout dans le territoire
national ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
nous avons d'immenses défis à relever là
dessus alors le sait l'hôpital public
est malade depuis des années ce que
cette crise du corps navire le ca a
révélé des failles du système sanitaire
français
je crois qu une des grosses failles du
système sanitaire français
c'est cette rupture entre une pratique
qu'on peut appeler privé une pratique
qu'on peut appeler public contre
demeurant réalité demande de financement
différent ce n'est pas ça que le coc
vide a montré au contraire le comines a
montré qu'on était capable de travailler
ensemble
nous avons transféré beaucoup de
patients à partir des urgences des
hôpitaux publics vers des établissements
privés cliniques d'aidé explique des
hôpitaux privés participant au service
public et nous avons tous travaillé la
main dans la main c'est lorsque nous
nous nous sommes capables de travailler
tous ensemble pour une valeur parce que
nous avons une mission claire et nous
sommes tous décidés à l'atteindre que
notre système de santé est opérationnel
et efficace lorsque le système de route
de santé se fait la concurrence entre
ses différentes composantes
c'est malsain et c'est ça qui nous met
en difficulté
aujourd'hui ce qui met en difficulté le
système de sang dit et c'est la quantité
de postes vacants d'infirmières de
médecins surtout dans des services
difficile à garde comme les urgences par
exemple mais il n'ya pas que les
urgences je suis pas du tout
corporatiste dans ce sujet il ya
beaucoup d'autres disciplines qui sont
en très grande difficulté et c'est la
concurrence qu'on se joue entre nous
tout ce qu'ils font qui fait que
les médecins les soignants ne savent
plus trop bien sûr quel système
s'orienter sur quels services
il faut participer et aujourd'hui il ya
une véritable problématique le problème
est essentielle le problème essentiel
est de recruter d'avoir des gens qui
travaillent dans le terrain et ce n'est
pas qu'une question d'argent
parce que très souvent les budgets
existe mais il n'y a pas les personnes
qui sont prêtes à venir travailler dans
ces services est difficile là où il ya
une pénurie des conditions de travail
beaucoup plus important merci beaucoup
henrique casalino d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je rappelle vous êtes chef du
service d'urgence de l'hôpital bichat et
nous sommes toujours en direct avec
cette cérémonie du 14 juillet une
édition 2020 qui débute par un hommage
au général charles de gaulle
annie à l'occasion d'un trip
anniversaire plusieurs tableaux sont
prévues avec notamment des chars de la
seconde guerre mondiale regarde ensemble
en direct cette cérémonie
le chemin
[Musique]
vous
de plus
[Musique]
m
comme le prévoyait le général de gaulle
dans un appel à résister le conflit
devient michael les 1942 l'armée
française d'afrique rejoint les alliés
le vent de la victoire commence à
souffler alger le 3 juin 1944 le général
de gaulle prend la tête du gouvernement
provisoire de la république française et
promis de le 9 août une ordonnance
rétablissant la légalité républicaine
en parallèle il dose avec le conseil
national de la résistance
les faux en politique de la france
d'après-guerre le 6 juin les alliés
débarquent au moment dés le 14 juin le
général traversé la manche à bord du
torpilleur la combattante et débarque
sur la côte normande à bayonne l'une des
premières villes libérées il prononce un
discours destiné à imposer son autorité
et asseoir la france à la table des
vainqueurs
il reçoit du peuple français un accueil
enthousiaste il obtient du général
eisenhower que paris soit libéré par la
division leclerc le 25 août
paris est enfin libre le nom de marc le
général des 100 triomphalement les
champs elysées devant une foule en
liesse et réaffirme la permanence de la
république libérer la france n'est pas
encore victorieuse elle poursuit le
combat aux côtés des alliés
[Musique]
mais pas toujours
on
[Musique]
où
mais
[Musique]
oui
il
[Musique]
le 8 mai 1945 le général de lattre de
tassigny représente la france à berlin
pour la signature de la capitulation de
l'allemagne nazie puis le maréchal
leclerc à tokyo pour celle du japon la
france retrouve son statut de grande
puissance
le 17 janvier de l'année suivante elle
intègre le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
devenu président de la république en
décembre 1958 le général de gaulle
s'impose comme le défenseur de
l'indépendance stratégique de la france
il soutient de programme de dissuasion
dtr débuter au cours des années
précédentes
en parallèle il lance la modernisation
des forces armées
convaincu de la nécessité de la
construction européenne pour assurer la
paix avec tous chancelier adenauer
il pose les fondations de l'amitié
franco allemande à la fin de la décennie
la france a retrouvé sa souveraineté
militaire et une radio matic qui lui
permet de renouer avec l'idée de
grandeur chère au général de gaulle
[Musique]
toute ma vie je me suis fait une
certaine idée de la france le sentiment
vous inspire aussi bien que la raison
j'ai d'instinct l'impression que la
providence l'a créée pour des succès
achevés ou des malheurs exemplaire mais
aussi le côté positif de mon esprit me
convainc que la france dé réellement
mêmes qu'au premier rang que seul le
rasta entreprises sont susceptibles de
compenser les ferments de dispersion que
son top porte en lui-même que notre pays
tel qu'il est parmi réseaux tels qu'ils
sont wam sous peine de danger mortel
viser haut et se sentir droit bref à mon
sens la france nous peut être la france
sans la bande heures
[Musique]
je trace les bases que nous souhaitons
donner aux institutions renouvelé de la
france ces vases elles sont définies par
les trois devises des français remy nous
disons honneur et patrie entendant par
là que la nation pour 1 re vivre que par
la victoire
il subsiste et que dans le culte de sa
propre grandeur disons liberté égalité
fraternité parce que notre volonté est
de rester fidèle aux principes
démocratiques
nous disions libération car si le trésor
ne saurait se terminer avant la défaite
de l'ennemi il doit avoir comme
aboutissement pour chacun des français
une condition hôtel qui lui soit
possible de vivre et de travailler dans
la dignité et la sécurité
il faut que la défense de la france soit
française un pays comme la france
s'il lui arrive de faire la guerre il
faut que ce soit sa guerre il faut que
son effort
soissons d'efforts s'il en était
autrement notre pays serait en
contradiction avec tout ce qu'il est
d'office les origines avec son rôle avec
les styles qu'il a de lui-même
je
en français
[Musique]
et aérien qui a commencé dans le ciel de
paris on va poursuivre cette édition
spéciale avec notre invité françois
souvent si en direct donc sur rtl france
soit un choix aussi bonjour vous êtes
général de brigade et expert en
géostratégie merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin
une parade militaire aérienne réduite un
public absent pour raison de crise
sanitaire quelle est l'importance
symbolique de ce défilé du 14 juillet
pour le corps militaire qui finalement
cette année et voilà est en comité
restreint place de la concorde
je crois qu'il faut rétablir sa dans son
contexte
d'abord le 14 juillet est une fête
nationale à laquelle les armées sont
forcément partie prenante mais pas
qu'elle
d'ailleurs le thème du 14 juillet est
très claire aujourd'hui 1 s'est unie
solidaire
donc je crois que c'est important le
deuxième point aussi qu'est ce que le 14
juillet le 14 juillet ce n'est pas la
démolition de la bastille où la prise de
la bastille
c'est surtout 1790 et non pas 1789 c'est
à dire la fête de la fédération
la fête de l'unité nationale c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui quand on voit des
manifestations dans paris que sera la
cgt ou gilet jaune on peut s'étonner
qu'on oublie que le 14 juillet c'est la
fête de l'unité nationale et qu'on doit
laisser de côté toutes ses
revendications au moins pour la journée
et puis maintenant pour les armées ce
qui est important c'est de bien montrer
que la zone est présent dans la crise
pas forcément d'une manière énorme
compte tenu de nos moyens mais on était
là on a montré que l'état était là par
ses armées et les armées ont largement
contribué au début de la crise a été
notamment les soignants à faire face à
cette crise
justement vous parlez du rôle de l'armée
l'armée qui avait donc participer à
cette lutte contre le corps à des virus
avec l'opération résilience en mettant
notamment à disposition des avions en
transportant des soignants en formant
des hôpitaux de militaires également est
ce le rôle de l'armée justement en temps
de crise sanitaire d'être présente
alors je dirais qu'en temps de crise en
général
l'armée reste pour moi au moins est pour
beaucoup de militaires
le dernier recours
de la nation pour faire face à n'importe
quelle crise les militaires sont
disponibles 24 heures sur 24 n'ont pas
de droit de retrait ne cherche le
réclame pas ne sont jamais en grève et
sont toujours disponibles
c'est la négation c'est le service de la
patrie quelle que soit la crise
maintenant sur le coville
nous avons des moyens nous avons montré
que nous pouvions aider l'état à faire
face les hôpitaux en particulier et nous
avons des moyens avec le service de
santé des armes des armes et qui est
aujourd'hui mis aussi en valeur
plus de dix mille militaires de la
direction de centrale du service des
armées ont été utilisés
nous avons huit hôpitaux d'instruction
et nous avons plus de 2000 médecins
on ne peut pas négliger cette force
supplémentaire pour faire face à une
crise telle que l'aco vide alors la
patrouille de france 1 est en train de
survoler la place de la concorde pour la
fin de l'hommage au général charles de
gaulle puisque cette année voilà on
célèbre un triple anniversaire trois
tableaux étaient présentes et qui
retrace les moments forts de la vie du
général
un général qui marquera qui a marqué la
france à tout jamais on le voit encore
avec emmanuel macron qui a voulu lui
rendre hommage en janvier tout à fait je
crois qu'il faut bien réfléchir à qui
était charles de gaulle
charles de gaulle est finalement un
officier presque comme les autres
saint cyrien engagés dans la guerre de
14 18 qui a été fait prisonnier après a
servi en pologne
justement pour participer au réveil de
la pologne
ensuite surtout il a été reconnu
identifié par le pouvoir politique comme
étant quelqu'un qui avait des idées car
il a écrit entre les deux guerres et
c'est surtout le symbole de la
résistance le symbole du refus de la
défaite le symbole de celui qui veut la
victoire même s'il est tout seul
et finalement même les gens de gauche
qui l'ont beaucoup décrié quand il était
au pouvoir
nous commençons par mitterrand jusqu'à
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui marine le
pen
les politiques aujourd'hui se réfère
tout ça de bol pourquoi parce que de
gaulle était un officier qui avait un
sens politique mais un sens politique et
qui permettait aussi de d'abord mettre
la france d'abord et les parties ensuite
et c'est pour ça que nous avons une
constitution qui zappe celle de la vème
république qui fait de la france qui
donne à la france à un régime
présidentiel avec un président de la
république est aussi chef des armées
d'où emmanuel macron aujourd'hui chef
des armées réel pas uniquement pour
simplement pour le montrer et il est
vraiment chef des armées et c'est de
gaulle qui a mis ça en place car il sait
que la france a besoin de gouverner il
sait que la france a besoin d'avoir un
régime fort avec un exécutif puissant
même si d'aucuns le regretterai et
finalement quel que soit le parti
politique sans doute à par l'extrême
gauche disent bien que charles de gaulle
est un exemple par sept en officier et
un officier montre l'exemple
c'est ce qu'a fait de boules justement
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron va essayer de montrer
l'exemple on sait que le chef de l'état
va s'exprimer à la télévision
la traditionnelle interview du 14
juillet pourtant il l'avait voilà
annulées auparavant et l'a finalement
pour pour cette édition 2020 il va se
prêter au jeu
oui mais je crois que personnellement
j'estime que c'est bien en tant qu' un
chef
un exemple impressionnant république en
période de crise doit montrer qu'il est
là il doit répondre aux attentes des
citoyens
le 14 juillet fête de l'unité nationale
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure qui est
quand même là où théoriquement on met
dehors tous et tous ces a priori
ben on va écouter le président la
république qui va apporter des messages
qui va donner des informations
alors effectivement aujourd'hui ça ne
sera pas un exercice convenu comme avant
et on peut comprendre la critique de
générer de ce 14 juillet où chaque
maison de république qui aimante parler
pour ne rien dire
là comment pourrions-nous comprendre
qu'un président de la république en
temps de crise sociale économique
éventuellement point des mythes ne
puisse pas s'exprimer et ne s'exprime
pas devant la nation et finalement le 14
juillet est la meilleure date possible
pour qu'un prénom d'un public s'exprime
alors le chef de l'état qui a également
prononcé un discours hier devant les
armées
voilà que les a remerciés on sait que
veulent installer 2020 n'a pas toujours
été facile pour eux est ce que c'est
important aujourd'hui pour le président
justement d'être aux côtés de son armée
de leur montrer voilà qu'ils
s'inquiètent également de leur moral oui
tout à fait le 14 juillet
traditionnellement est aussi sinon
devenu la journée des armées où on
montre l'armée française où elle défile
au oui mais ce n'est pas le défilé qui
est important c'est qu'elle est mise à
l'honneur
comme je disais il ya quelques instants
le président macron et chef des armées
il est responsable aussi de la condition
militaire du moral des armées surtout
que comme je l'étais aussi tout à
l'heure les militaires ne disent rien et
pis je trouve des solutions sans
contester il a des hommes et des femmes
qui s'engagent pour la france et qui
font passer leurs presque un intérêt
particulier bien nous de là bien après
l'intérêt général l'intérêt général
prime et je crois que le prénom de ma
chrome contenu de ses débuts difficiles
en 2017
avec le départ du général de villiers
qui a été comme une affaire
malencontreuse et pas très pas très
correct 1
le général de vider a quand même sauvé
ce qu'il fallait pour les armées pour
qu'elle fonctionne quand il était aux
affaires
et que cette crise certes temporaire à
imposer au président de la république
année après année on le constate depuis
2010 est à prendre l'armé en
considération à respecter des hommes et
les femmes qui la respectent respecter
ses chefs et s'est sans doute rendu
compte que quand ils demandaient quelque
chose lessard mais faisait elle ne
disait rien s agissait mais je crois que
dans une société qui est toujours en
train de de regimber sinon de le dire ah
bah non je ne ferai pas de sujet pourri
c'est bien pour un besoin d'un public
d'avoir une institution sur laquelle
pouvoir compter merci beaucoup
françois changement c'est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes général de brigade et expert
en géostratégie
les avions dans le ciel de paris on va
retrouver notre reporter et celle farges
estelle la patrouille de france et son
panache bleu blanc rouge a survolé la
cérémonie une cérémonie qui met à
l'honneur cette année les personnels
soignants qui ont été en première ligne
dans la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
où exactement doha une cérémonie a placé
sous le signe de la reconnaissance à la
rend actuellement c'est le défilé aérien
qui a pris place dans le ciel de la
capitale où une vingtaine d'hélicoptères
et une cinquantaine d'avions survolent
actuellement à paris un petit peu plus
tôt à cette cérémonie elle s'est ouvert
avec un hommage au général de gaulle
avec ce triple anniversaire
les 130 ans de sa naissance les 50 ans
de sa mort et les à 80 ans de l'appel du
hêtre 18 juin à 40 à 11h40 les troupes
défileront à pied sur la place de la
concorde et puis est la cérémonie et
s'achèvera avec un hommage aux soignants
c'est un format réduit pour cette
cérémonie qui devrait durer une heure 15
au lieu de deux heures avec deux mille
participants contre eux le double en
temps normal alors l'événement n'est pas
ouvert au public 1 mais sachez qu'ils
sont tout de même plusieurs centaines à
s'être réunis ici pour être au plus près
des événements pour regarder ce défilé
aérien en tout seules deux mille cinq
cents personnes ont été officiellement
convié dont 1400 qui représentent lé
français qui ont été en première ligne
face à l'épidémie il y a des soignants
des familles de soignants décédé ducobu
19 des pompiers est aussi des salariés
d'une usine de masques par exemple une
nation engagée et unie et solidaire
c'est à l'esprit de ce 14 juillet 2000
20 une cérémonie un jeu les dix qui est
placée sous le signe de la
reconnaissance cette cérémonie a présidé
par emmanuel macron à mettre à l'honneur
la participation à des armées françaises
dans la lutte contre le coronavirus ce
sont ces unités qui ont oeuvré dans le
cadre de l'opération résilience qui a
été lancé le 25 mars dernier à part le
chef de l'état plusieurs troupes sont
représentés aujourd'hui c'est le cas par
exemple du régiment médical de l'armée
de terre sont élus ce sont à ces
militaires qui ont participé à
l'ouverture de l'hôpital de campagne à
mulhouse sont représentés également le
deuxième régiment des dragons qui est
qui ont assuré est la désinfection des
infrastructures et des transports
militaires reconnaissance envers nos
militaires mais aussi vous l'avez dit
envers nos personnels soignants qui ont
permis donc de lutter contre l'épidémie
et reconnaissance en vain enfin envers
nos voisins européens puisqu'à quatre
pays sont a symboliquement représentée
aujourd'hui l'allemagne l'autriche la
suisse le luxembourg pour les remercier
d'avoir accueilli dans leurs hôpitaux
des patients français attendu
coronavirus merci beaucoup à estelle
farges pour toutes ces précisions
[Musique]
à présent c'est la légion étrangère que
l'on voit à l'image acquis parade devant
le chef de l'état allait on va continuer
à parler de ce 14 juillet inédit et
exceptionnel nous sommes en direct avec
nicolas vidal directeur de la
publication de putsch médias nicolas
vidal bonjour merci des mots en direct
sur rt france alors ce 14 juillet le
premier depuis 1979 a célébré son défilé
militaire sur les champs elysées
beaucoup regrettent elles l'absence de
la traditionnelle parade militaire est
ce que vous partagez cet avis va ya une
critique coronavirus bien entendu qui a
fait un format réduit c'est c'est un peu
le but aussi de cette cette
manifestation de cette célébration en
dirons nous du 14 juillet sept portement
symbolique pour les français parce que
c'est aussi la concorde 1 le rappellera
à la fessée la prise de la bastille du
14 juillet mais aussi c'est la fête des
fédérations appelé par le commandement
lafayette donc duc 2 799 de 4,90 pardon
donc c'est aussi cette fête n'a cette
célébration c'est la france qui se
retrouve c'est la france qui commit donc
pour moi aujourd'hui je vais être un peu
taquin mais cette scène elle un goût
finalement cette célébration du 14
juillet
au menu m'apprendre du schizophrénie
finalement historique parce qu emmanuel
macron le sait avec la politique qu'il a
menée aujourd'hui sur sur l'ensemble de
la france depuis deux ans c'est assez
c'est assez étonnant
voilà dans le symbole donc le ces
symboles contre symbol le symbole de la
nation retrouvait la concorde au regard
ça sur la place de la concorde c'est ton
nez et finalement aussi une politique d'
emmanuel macron qui ne croient pas
beaucoup en la france si on pourra en
reparler
alors le président qui va également s
exprimer après cette cérémonie à la
télévision alors on le sait il avait
déjà renoncé à cette traditionnelle
allocution présidentielle du 14 juillet
finalement aujourd'hui il va se prêter
au jeu
comment peut-il rassurer les français
sur sa capacité à diriger le pays à le
sortir de la crise alors que sa cote de
popularité est en baisse
alors premières informations ce matin
j'ai fait ma revue grèce et j'ai lu chez
les confrères du figaro chez nos
confrères du figaro qu emmanuel macron
avait failli annuler cette femme est
entretien vendredi après-midi dans la
précipitation finalement il a même tenu
donc emmanuel macron on imagine que
l'entretien avec m disruptif et vous
savez ce mot à la mode dans l'équipe de
communication du manuel macro ni
subversif
qu'est ce qui va faire emmanuel macron
il va continuer à dérouler son projet
parce qu emmanuel mâcon la différence du
général de gaulle on rappellera qu'un
hommage au général de gaulle sur ce
défilé du 14 juillet et c'est bien
normal
une manière macro il ya ce projet donc
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va nous
remettre sur la table la réforme des
retraites la réforme d'assurance chômage
donc cet entretien est finalement vous
savez il a parlé 600 jours en conseil
ministre emmanuel m'apprendre moi je
crois que ça va être finalement
l'affirmation des 600 prochains jours de
galère pour les français donc je crois
qu'il va continuer il a continué à
dérouler son programme face dans cet
entretien la chose qui l'avait emmené en
2017 et qui remis au goût du jour mais
une petite précision tout de même la
seule chose que je vois là c'est qu'ils
emmanuel macron est assez fébrile sur le
temps de la communication voilà il ya un
projet gelé toujours dit sur vos
antennes mais même le projet très clair
il sait où il va que ça plaise ou non
c'est comme ça il sait où il va mais par
contre en terme de communication comment
je le sais un peu fébrile emmanuel
macron et cette annulation 7e non
annulation de dernière minute montre
quand même laisse apparaître une
certaine fébrilité dans la communication
sait comment jouer parle aux français
qu'est ce que je vais leur dire mais
finalement je vais leur dire la même
chose qu'il ya depuis deux ans où elle a
pas mais les hommages qui sont rendus ce
matin lors de cette cérémonie du 14
juillet on l'a dit elle est le personnel
hospitalier qui étaient en première
ligne mais surtout le général du goût de
gaulle la figure historique du général
de gaulle revendiquons un petit peu cet
héritage justement
l'espé emmanuel mâcon veut redorer son
blason et ce qu'il cherche à se donner
une stature d'homme d'état
non pour moi c'est la schizophrénie est
absolu quand on va signer l'odieux
traiter des clashs l'appel il ya deux
ans et qui engueule américain on peut
pas se réclamer du gaullisme et encore
moins de ski et la souveraineté de la
france
moi je pense que manuel macron c'est un
hommage qui peut il peut pas ne peut pas
ne pas le faire cet hommage au général
de gaulle à la croix de lorraine
mais il a tellement abîmée l'amd france
emmanuel macron que je le redis une
nouvelle fois pour moi c'est à ce goût
absolu de schizophrénie historique
donc oui john le bol on ne peut pas
entendre pour les souverainistes et les
amoureux de la france les français sur
la nation et du territoire de
l'enracinement de gaulle est un
visionnaire de gaulle et l'homme d'état
le goal est l'homme de la vision pour la
france de la grandeur de la france donc
emmanuel lincot il correspond pas du
tout une coche aucune case du gaullisme
c'est même moi pour moi j'avais dit sur
l'antenne ces langues qui de golf annuel
alors le chef de l'état qui va prendre
la parole pour la première fois depuis
le remaniement ministériel
nous sommes à deux ans de la
présidentielle
est ce qu'il est déjà en campagne
elle n'a point sa langue ou alors il est
en campagne sur lui peut-être
effectivement mais c'est surtout qui fut
je le redis tout en un c'est qu'il a un
projet manuel macron et qu'il doit
absolument aller d'ici 2000 2022 il
mettre ces réformes centrale la réforme
des retraites si sa réforme mer dont
emmanuel macron il a continué à pilonner
avec cette réforme des retraites alors
qu'ils servent
il va peut être se représente pour moi
finalement ce projet là s'il estime que
ce projet là n'est pas terminée à la fin
de son mandat il se représentera
emmanuel macron parce que j'ai toujours
vu finalement comment le directeur
général des services de l'union
européenne de bruxelles pour lequel il
ya une feuille de route qui veut mettre
en place et la réforme des retraites
c'est vraiment son son kart à emmanuel
macron est alors oui il va perdre ils
peuvent proposer ils se présentent et
peut-être en 2022
mais concrètement ça ne sera toujours
sous l'homme de ce projet néolibéral qui
met en place et avec cet hommage de
soignants c'est quand même bien
dérisoire parce que le symbole il ne
doit pas être l'alibi de l'amendement et
du mépris pour le personnel soignant
justement dans ce conteste dans ce
contexte est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à
une rentrée sociale en septembre
explosive oui je vais vous dire oui
effectivement même d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui je crois que les soignants
manifeste à bastille et 14h des liaisons
sont près de l'igpn en ce moment donc
vous ce beau on comprend bien que déjà
le ferment explosif sociale est déjà là
on le dit à chaque fois
la crise économique va être
redoutablement terme de licenciement en
termes de jeunes qui vont arriver huit
cent mille jeunes qui vont arriver sur
le marché d'emploi
et puis une nouvelle fois ses réformes
imaginer ou la réforme de la réforme
d'assurance chômage pardon avec le
nombre de chômeurs considérable pour
septembre octobre
on est dans une folie absolue donc
forcément ça va générer des tensions
sociales des manifestations et personne
ne peut dire aujourd'hui qu'elle éveille
d'intensité et surtout ce qui est manuel
mâcon tu continues sa feuille de route
bien marquer avec son stylo rouge
oui c'est sûr et certain que la cie
change pas de cap changera pas de cap
enfin soyons très clairs oui c'est on va
s'affronter il va s'affronter mais
nouvelle macro à une tension sociale
redoutable qui va être agrégées par ce
que j'appelle depuis un certain temps
l'agrégat des colères finalement cette
agri vers des colères qui barrent donc
va être rejoint par une série de gens
sont au chômage sur la précarité la
paupérisation et et oui mais
mille mais qu'on changera pas de cap pas
une seule seconde merci beaucoup
nicolas vidal d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de la publication de coach
meziane
la présence entre autour des
hélicoptères et
la de sillonner le ciel de paris on
regarde ces images en direct ce défilé
du 14 juillet un défilé inédit et en
comité restreint place de la concorde
[Musique]
que nous
je
et
[Musique]
oui
notamment pas
on
orthez
[Musique]
m
au nom en haut
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
m
mon
[Musique]
vous
on
[Musique]
nous
et
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
ah bon
je
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
je
et
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
oui
et
le
[Musique]
mais
m
[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
le monde
ap
[Musique]
voilà après les hélicoptères c'est donc
défilé des troupes à pied les militaires
qui font le tour de la place de la
concorde dans le sens inverse des
aiguilles d'une montre
parmi les membres qui sont présents on
retrouve les emblèmes des kpi mise à
l'honneur cette année
l'autriche le luxembourg et la suisse
voilà ces pays qui ont aucune idée des
patients français atteint du pays 19
lorsque nos hôpitaux les hôpitaux
français était saturé on va parler de
cette cérémonie exceptionnelle avec
notre invité michel cofondateur de
pignons internationale ami ciel de bons
jours merci d'être en direct sur rt
france voilà quatre pays invités 1 sont
à son talonneur l'allemagne l'autriche
le luxembourg et la suisse
c'est une façon de les remercier pour
leur aide pendant la crise sanitaire
effectivement parce que deux français
roux était très très durement frappés
l'impact et big four en abribus et comme
malheureusement beaucoup de victimes
étaient dans l'est de la foule régionaux
je suis moi même originaire dans le haut
rhin
il y avait un moment donné tu es
vraiment saturation des hôpitaux de
mulhouse de colmar communes aux
alentours et l'allemagne la suisse
l'autre michel soro ont recueilli 52 que
les malades et ils auront sauvé la vie
dont effectivement puisque le président
à vie à sur la pression de l'iphone 6
est décidé d'élargir un petit peu le
thème du 14 juillet à aux victimes du
coronavirus et à celles et ceux qui ont
protégé les français
pendant cette crise il était donc temps
de saluer le cpie prévôté solidaire eu
fort de la crise alors que le défilé
traditionnel du 14 juillet
chaque année attendu par des millions de
français des milliers de personnes
d'ailleurs assiste en direct cet
événement avec voilà
le défilé sur les champs-elysées ce que
vous comprenez un petit peu cette
frustration de certains français qui
voient là cette année
regarde ce défilé un petit peu restera 1
place de la concorde
et guti non moi je suis pas tellement
d'accord parce qu'en fait je trouve vous
retransmis tv même les images de de ce
défilé en dieu mais je trouve que ça
renouvelle en fait d'exercice on voit
paris autrement on le voit d'un autre
point de vue
d'ailleurs on dit que paris la plus
belle ville du monde je sais pas si
c'est vrai c'est bien prétend se le dire
mais c'est quand même à belleville et on
le voit sur les images diffusées non je
pense que justement cette crise est
peut-être l'occasion de réinventer de
vos visites et aux symboles nous les
traditions de nos symboles et je trouve
que finalement c'est pas mal que que
cela change un petit peu se sont pas
tous les ans les mêmes images
là on voit autrement l'armée française
on voit également des soignants
d'ailleurs avait-il dit que les premiers
de cordée notamment les soignants les
médecins premières dépouilles des
pompiers tous les autres cas présent
choses qu'on ne voit pas assez et je
trouve que ça renouvelle un petit peu
l'exercice
ils peuvent pour tout vous dire moi dans
mon magazine prix international on est
très attaché à faire vivre le symbole
mais aussi à les renouveler la façon
dont on les transmet on a par exemple
lancé hier avec des gros sportif
c'est l'initiative une minute de sueur
pour la france salue est justement de
premier plan des je vous invite pas les
ratios sur notre site internet
opinion internationale mais très
concrètement je pense que les images que
l'on voit en ce moment même s'ils ont
une manière pour renouveler cet exercice
commémorative cet exercice de faire
vivre les valeurs de la nation et
honnêtement moi je trouve ça bien le
bien de loin les choses autrement et ça
mais ça met un peu de nouveauté
alors justement cette édition 2020 est
né dit voilà pas de public que 2500
personnes ont été conviées par 1400
soignants mais aussi des professions qui
ont été en première ligne voire en
seconde ligne durant cette crise
sanitaire
est-ce que c'était important ce geste
symbolique de rendre hommage à toutes
ces personnes à la tire ont fait face à
cette crise sanitaire
alors oui bien entendu j'avais lancé un
appel dans mon magazine pour que les
premiers cordes et c'est à dire les
soignants mais aussi les magasiniers les
dockers les transporteurs les caissiers
dans les magasins tout ce que fait vivre
le pays au plus fort du confinement
défilent en tête sur les champs-elysées
ou place de la concorde
et c'est vrai que beaucoup ont été
invités ils sont sur la place de la
concorde
certains des films notamment des
soignants mais de l'armée française
moi je trouve que leur équipe de
majorque ton que en fait en tête de ceux
de ceux de ce défilé on voit des de
faire le tour de la place de la concorde
des milliers de soignants et des
milliers de 2 encore une fois de tous
ces corps de métier qui a subi
qui assurent la manutention qui font
tourner la machine france et sans
lesquels nous pourrions pas pour ne pas
vivre tout simplement
donc effectivement il ya une bonne
intention au niveau de la réalisation ça
reste quand même un événement surtout
militaire je pense pour ma part que nous
avons deux armées en france on à l'armée
française et l'armée des militaires et
des forces de sécurité qui est
indispensable à la sécurité de notre
pays qu'il faut saluer comme on le fait
tous les 14 juillet ils vont plus un
rôle déterminant pour notre pays
notamment dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et dans des théâtres
d'opérations extérieures plus de 550
français sont morts dans le cadre
d'opérations extérieures depuis 1963
donc il faut les saluer mais on a eu 2e
armée française qui est celle des
soignants de tous les laits les cordes
de la société qui font vivre la société
les manutentionnaires et transporter les
éboueurs les dockers ils sont des
milliers des dizaines que des milliers
ils sont des centaines de démons de
milliers et c'est eux aussi notre
deuxième année process et j'aurais voulu
qu'ils qu'ils soient tout aussi présente
les militaires à leurs côtés pour ce 14
juillet on a l'impression que le
président de la république a tenu à
repenser cette célébration du 14 juillet
ce qu'aujourd'hui justement c'est dans
l'air du temps de repenser peut-être les
célébrations des grandes dates de la
république selon vous je pense que c'est
plus que de les repenser ses de
renouveler les modes de célébration
c'est alex effectivement notamment pour
les jeunes générations qui souvent ne
comprennent pas ce que c'est que 14
juillet à quoi cela on voit qu as tu
sais le 11 novembre puisque c'est le 8
mai toutes ces grandes dates de
l'histoire
clic
un peu perdu de leur sens donc ravivé la
flamme de cette mémoire française comme
le font tous les goûts au pays les états
unis la russie tous les grandes nations
faut un grand travail de mémoire et de
ciné passion
je pense que c'est très important de
renouveler les boîtes de transmission
donc encore une fois un défilé militaire
c'est très bien mais je pense que de
dire qu'ils y adjoindre des ceux des
civils des personnes qui jouent un rôle
clé dans dans la vie de la société ça
c'est vraiment une très belle manière de
renouveler en fin d'exercice
et encore une fois je trouve que de voir
aujourd'hui des images différentes avec
ce superbe lampadaires de la ville de
paris dernière le nouveau gouvernement
d'arabie avec jean castex et nouveau
gouvernement
emmanuel macron on et ransart nouvelles
de l'image et la symbolique des symboles
de la république et je trouve que ça
fait du bien qui va s'exprimer à la
télévision qui va répondre aux questions
des journalistes à l'occasion justement
de cette interview du 14 juin
une interview très attendue par les
français que peut-on attendre justement
voilà de la part du chef de l'état est
ce qu'il va vouloir relancer la fin de
son quinquennat préparer peut-être les
prochaines présidentielles alors je
pense qu'il ne faut pas trop en
attendant pourquoi parce que nous sommes
à deux ans de l'élection présidentielle
à deux en deux ans il est très difficile
voire impossible de faire vous devez ou
de réaliser toutes les promesses sur
lequel on a été élu il ya trois ans
c'est à dire en 2017 emmanuel macron
faut pas se cacher il a beaucoup déçu il
a plus fait de grandes promesses aux
français il a souvent dans ses discours
portait une idée très hot de la
république française et de son mandat
mais la réalité c'est que dans les faits
son quinquennat a été jusqu'à présent un
cas qui n'a un peu horrible avec les
gilets jaunes avec les grèves très très
dur sur les retraites d'affaires benalla
et j'en passe donc effectivement 1,4 et
du coup vous n'alliez boscacci violente
si dur on a passé le cap des trente
mille morts c'est probablement
probablement une quarante mille parce
que beaucoup de français sont des
seconds sont morts à leur domicile et le
chiffrage est difficile à faire
donc avec cette crise terrible le chef
de l'état a voulu prendre l'opportunité
entre guillemets de cette crise pour
tenter de relancer son quinquennat il a
parlé dans ce dernier glisse qu à tenter
de définir un nouveau chemin et c'est un
peu ce qu'il va essayer de des films de
destiné tout à l'heure dans l'interview
qu'il va donner dans dans un peu plus
d'une heure de à deux journalistes pour
les deux devant les devant les français
mais honnêtement encore une fois à deux
ans de la fin de pierre de quinquennat
et quand bien même il aurait changé
premiers ministres edouard philippe qui
a été remplacé par jean castex
il ya maintenant dix jours je pense que
ça va être très très difficile de
changer de cap
sinon d'ajuster certaines choses mais
honnêtement qu'il ne faut pas s'attendre
à des merveilles
moi je pense plutôt qu'ils manuel macron
son interview de 13 heures le 14 juillet
sa première interview du 14 juillet
depuis qu'il est président de la
république
ce sera pour moi plus le coup dès le
coup d'envoi de sa campagne électorale
ça aussi bloqué élections pour sa
candidature en 2022 véritablement des
annonces tonitruantes qui vont changer
la vie des français dans les prochains
mois quels défis attendent le chef de
l'état là deux ans de la fin de son
mandat aujourd'hui seront là je crois
que le premier défi c'est de calmer
l'opinion publique parce que honnêtement
les tensions sociales ont été exclus en
vie depuis maintenant plus d'un an
depuis novembre 2018 et le déclenchement
de la crise il est jour le 17 novembre
on a eu sans cesse sans cesse sans cesse
des grèves des manifestations de rue des
violences urbaines
le climat social et et la concorde
civile abriel défilé a lieu place de la
concorde est ce que les français vivent
dans la concorde aujourd'hui
malheureusement la réponse est non et
c'est vrai que après la crise et gilet
jaune
après la clef des retraites après la
caisse du corps d'un virus tue en 1010
l'avenir côté représente à lui seul de
calmer les choses pour que nous
puissions terminer ce quartier d'arc
audience correcte en termes de stabilité
en terme de violence aussi annonce a
commencé la grande priorité
si à la vente pt6a la route et à kalou
quelques mesures pour ce soir le plus
d'amants il y a de nouveau des grèves
massives ya nouveau une colère sociale
cette colère française quitte la table
vous êtes vous complètement ça va être
très très difficile pour le président la
république d'assumer et de finir son
mandat voire même d'envisager d'être
candidat en 2020 donc ça pour moi c'est
la priorité
la deuxième priorité évidemment c'est
une relance économique très très forte
très très ambitieuse que doute doit
annoncer le premier ministre à la fin du
mois d'août
début septembre et qui doivent enzo et
manuel macumba peut-être dessiner les
contours tout à l'heure dans dans
l'interview présidentielle c'est de
faire une grande violence économique qui
permette de créer des centaines de
milliers d'emplois pour compenser les
nombreux licenciements qui ont déjà été
engagés qui vont continuer continuer à
l'être dans l'est dans les prochaines
semaines à la suite de la crise de
couronnes environ
donc là il ya un défi il faut que l'état
français
moi je suis un libéral dont puissiez
vous faire confiance aux gens pour faire
tourner l'économie
et lorsqu'il y à une crise terrible et
là c'est ce que nous vivons l'état
stratège
l'état français doit être très présent
en subvenir aux manquements d'associer
donc bien il faut maintenant que l'état
soit présent qu'ils prennent des mesures
simples forte direct pour pouvoir
amorcer la relance économique
qui permettra d'éviter le pire parce
qu'encore une fois notamment si la pleut
il ya 2-0 vague pandémique qui nous
arrive et qu'il tourne dessus
la situation va vraiment vraiment très
difficile à tignes en voilà pour moi
deux des priorités et j'ai envie d'y 23e
et c'est la dernière qui avait annoncé
notamment par le premier ministre pour
le jean castex à plusieurs reprises il
faut le saluer c'est le réaffirmer les
principes d'autorité de l'état de
respect de la lettre et voyez la surface
agricole il ya les sociale et la 2007
public est liberté égalité fraternité
moi j'y ajoute la laïcité pour bientôt
mais l'autorité de l'état le respect de
nos ventes le pauliste respect de la
laïcité parce que au point une forme
termes de valeur il ya eu beaucoup de
manquements titanium - personne et c'est
très important de les réaffirmer nous
sommes en france
nous ne sommes pas dans un autre pays la
france a des valeurs soient civiles
elles sont universelles belle son
française avant tout et il ne voulait
rien
olé merci beaucoup michel d'hooghe
d'avoir réagi sur votre antenne je
rappelle que vous êtes fondateur
l'opinion internationale
[Musique]
passage des hélicoptères les troupes à
pied de l'armée qui ont donc défilé
place de la concorde et toutes personnes
qui se sont ensuite dirigés vers la
madeleine via la rue royale et puis là
nous voyons donc et les militaires à
l'image avec le drapeau de la france et
le personnel soignant voilà médecins
soignants infirmiers
à
sont à présent sur la place de la
concorde où le public voilà les 2500
invités un rendent hommage à tous ceux
et celles qui ont été en première ligne
pendant cette crise sanitaire hommage
national donc aux soignants
[Musique]
mais tous les corps de métiers qui ont
été en deuxième ligne qui sied éboueurs
tous ont applaudi un par le chef de
l'état et le gouvernement
une cérémonie du 14-juillet inédite dans
un contexte exceptionnel un contexte de
crise sanitaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
m
allez
[Musique]
oh
et
pour les anglais présentée au
[Musique]
m
on
en pleurs
elle
le temps de la reine mais quand on est
bon
mbaye
ils viennent pas
et qu'on sait
[Musique]
et vous
à l'essai
à
[Musique]
à mon sens
à
on lui sociale
[Rires]
et
oh
avec les français
m
météo france
sous nos drapeaux
à
oh
le récent
les profits ont droit
[Musique]
larcher
à
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entendre la marseillaise et cet hommage
au personnel soignant sous les
applaudissements personnel soignant mais
également d'autres corps de métiers qui
ont été présents en première ligne
pendant cette crise sanitaire crise du
corona un virus
quand on voit beaucoup
d'applaudissements pour ces personnes
présentes aujourd'hui place de la
concorde
2500 personnes sont dans les gradins
parmi eux 1400 le soignant infirmiers
médecins caissiers caissières aussi
éboueurs tous ceux qui ont été donc en
première ligne pendant ces crises
sanitaires
on va retrouver estelle farges donc en
direct notre reporter voilà leur vient
de le voir ce défilé du 14 juillet a été
un défilé inédit cérémonie inédite en
raison bien évidemment de la crise du
coronavirus pour clôturer le défilé le
drapeau français on le voit sur ces
images est porté par le service
militaire à qui on se souvient des
soignants civiles et militaires des
médecins des infirmiers des aides
soignants tous sont tenues
professionnelles
c'est l'hommage aux soignants c'était
une cérémonie exceptionnelle
estelle oui exactement doha et une
cérémonie à qui vient donc de qui
s'achève donc par un hommage aux
soignants alors l'événement n'était pas
ouvert au public mais vous allez pouvoir
le voir sur ces images de nicolas
winckler ils sont tout de même plusieurs
centaines à être venus ici aux abords de
la place de la concorde venus assister
au plus près des événements venus
applaudir aussi les troupes ans qui ont
défilé place de la concorde alors vous
l'avez dit elle cette édition 2020 est
un petit peu particulière puisqu'elle
est en format réduit à la durée 1h15 au
lieu de deux heures avec deux mille
participants contre le double en temps
normal une édition à 2020 qui s'est
ouvert avec un hommage au général de
gaulle à l'occasion de ce triple
anniversaire les 130 ans de sa naissance
les 50 ans de sa mort et les à 91 ans de
l appel du 18 juin avec 40 une cérémonie
a placé sous le signe de la
reconnaissance avec pour thème une
nation engagée unie et solidaire cette
cérémonie présidée par emmanuel macron a
mis à l'honneur la participation des
armées dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus ces unités qui honteuse rien
dans le cadre de l'opération résilience
qui a été lancé le 25 mars dernier par
emmanuel macron plusieurs troupes
aujourd'hui ont été représentés comme
par exemple le régiment
médical de l'armée de terre ce sont eux
qui ont été mobilisés dans l'ouverture
de l'hôpital de campagne à mulhouse
représenté aussi le deuxième régiment
des dragons qui eux ont assuré par
exemple la désinfection des
infrastructures et des transports
militaires une reconnaissance donc
envers nos militaires mais aussi vous
l'avez dit envers nos pères en perd nos
personnels soignants et civils qui ont
été en première ligne dans cette lutte
contre l épidémie de coronavirus et
enfin reconnaissance envers nos voisins
européens puisque quatre pays étaient
aujourd'hui a symboliquement représenté
l'allemagne l'autriche la suisse et le
luxembourg pour les remercier d'avoir
accueilli dans leurs hôpitaux des
patients français attendu coronavirus
merci est elle fâche pour toutes ces
précisions et on voit donc le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron qui est allé
saluer justement voilà toutes ces
personnes qui sont des médecins des
soignants mais aussi les infirmiers et
d'autres corps de métiers qui ont
participé à cette lutte contre le
coronavirus elle la cérémonie du 14
juillet qu'il y ait un donc voilà qui
prend qui prend enfin à 14 juillet
inédit sans défiler sans parade
militaire sur les champs elysées
une cérémonie tout de même place de la
concorde avec on l'a vu dans le ciel de
paris
la parade militaire des avions qui ont
donc voilà qui qui était bien là bien
présent avec les couleurs de la france
bleu blanc rouge on va tout de suite
retrouvé françois cocq essayiste pour
réagir justement à cette cérémonie et
inédit du 14 juillet françois cocq
bonjour merci d'être en direct sur rtl
france un honneur un hommage par don
symbolique justement aux soignants mais
aussi à toutes les personnes qui ont
participé à la lutte contre le
coronavirus est-ce que ce geste
symbolique est à la hauteur des enjeux
qui secoue actuellement le service
public de santé
écoutez c'est bien le moins que vous
pouvez faire l'état en termes de
reconnaissance vis-à-vis de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont lutté et qui
ont finalement été les premiers de
corvée et ils ne se sont pas défilés
contrairement à beaucoup dans la crise
que nous avions que nous avions devant
nous et pour autant on voit que loin du
faste et de l'objet communicationnel qui
est présenté par à part monsieur macron
avec ce défilé du 14-juillet bien
finalement le peuple et toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont la tâche aujourd'hui
de reconstruire le pays s'organisent par
eux mêmes et je note que
là où monsieur macro célèbre par exemple
les armées pour la porte qui a été
apportée pendant là pendant la crise
dont on peut se demander s'il était
légitime finalement si utile je pense
notamment au rapport des sapeurs
pompiers qui disait que certaines
opérations qui avaient été organisés
avec l'armée pour des transports de
patients étaient plus des opérations de
communication que réellement utile et
bien à côté de ces célébrations là il ya
une célébration populaire à celle des
soignants qui s'organise qui a eu lieu
ce matin dans les différentes
préfectures de nos départements qui aura
lieu cet après midi à paris entre
république et bastille et finalement le
peuple se prend en main à côté du
spectacle qui est donné aujourd'hui
vous savez une célébration a toujours un
objet est celle du 14 juillet
normalement elle célèbre l'union du
peuple
elle célèbre sa capacité à se forger et
à abattre l'arbitraire c'est c'est le
symbole de la prise de la bastille avec
ont célébré le 14 juillet au départ au
chant du ça ira celui qui lie à ça ira
ça ira à l'égalité partout règnera eh
bien on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la
situation post kobe d'ailleurs qui n'est
pas des plus une discussion posco vite
quand on regarde la situation sanitaire
aujourd'hui et bien cette situation là
n'est pas une situation où les gagner
l'égalité est mise sur le devant de la
scène et au contraire monsieur macro
entend sans servir pour aller plus loin
que loin dans son projet de
déstructuration de l'idéal républicain
justement on sait que des manifestations
vont avoir lieu cet après midi le
personnel de santé qui n'est pas
totalement satisfait par le ségur de la
santé certains voient cet hommage comme
une provocation face à ces
revendications salariales mais également
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
porté depuis des années ce que vous
partagez cet avis bien sûr puisque
il est fait et ce qui aujourd'hui nous
disent que il faut aider l'hôpital aidé
le service public ont beau jeu de dire
quand dès que nous ne sommes pas dans
une situation de crise il en profite
pour tailler dans les effectifs pour
déstructurer l'organisation du service
de soins pour le libéraliser le livrer à
la concurrence et aux et au privé est
donc aujourd'hui on voit l'état dans
lequel se situe notre service de santé
et celles et ceux qui se battent pour
l'améliorer comme ils ont été aux côtés
de toutes celles et tous ceux qui
étaient malades est victime de la crise
il ya quelques semaines mais ceux là ont
raison de dire que finalement ils ont
été méprisés pendant des années et
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une médaille en
chocolat dont ils ont besoin mais je
demande simplement à pouvoir faire
correctement leur travail dans les
meilleures conditions finalement c'est
ça que l'état devrait apporter plus tôt
que des parades qui elles ne servent que
de communication politicienne
pour le président de la république alors
le président de la république qui va
s'adresser aux français qui va répondre
aux questions des journalistes
dans peu de temps est ce que là aussi
vous y voyez une opération de
communication de la part du chef de
l'état où on tente il vraiment relancer
la fin de son quinquennat
je ne doute pas qu emmanuel macron en
organisant cette interview en revenant à
l'interview du 14 juillet et quelques
idées électoralistes en tête
preuve en est le choix qui a été fait
par lui et par ses équipes de celles et
ceux qui vont l'interviewer madame salam
salam et monsieur green qui ne sont
jamais rien d'autre que les caniches
médiatique du pouvoir et qui vont donc
servir la soupe à monsieur à monsieur
macro mais si monsieur macron avait de
réelles préoccupations il
s'intéresserait à ce qui se passe
réellement dans le pays ce qui se passe
dans le pays aujourd'hui c'est que le 9
juillet nous avions cinq cents soit six
nouveaux cas d'infection au coronavirus
autrement dit nous sommes revenus à des
chiffres qui sont ceux de début juin et
ils sont en constante augmentation
a marseille le nombre de nouveaux cas
double tous les deux jours et qu'a fait
monsieur macron il ya tout juste une
semaine
il a remplacé monsieur philippe par
monsieur castex là encore dans une
opération purement politiciennes en
enlevant le monsieur déconfinement de
son rôle en nous faisant finalement une
forme de
de nouvelles buzyn c'est à dire que
quelqu'un qui en place dans un secteur
clé et stratégiques
à un moment donné où la crise se joue
est retiré de son poste pour mener une
opération politicienne et électoraliste
je crois que monsieur macro honda
finalement que bien peu au coeur
l'avenir de notre pays et la santé des
françaises et des français et qu'ils
aient tous projetés effectivement vers
les élections de 2022 il faudra se
souvenir de ces épisodes
au moment de mettre un bulletin dans
l'urne comment est ce que vous voyez la
fin du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
c'est que voilà ça va être la première
fois que le chef d'état s'exprime depuis
le remaniement ministériel
dans quelques jours ce sera au tour de
jean castex de présenter
son discours de politique générale celui
qui va suivre en tout cas le plan qui
doit suivre pour les années à venir en
tout cas pour les deux ans qui restent à
emmanuel macron au pouvoir la stratégie
de monsieur leproux semble clair son
nouveau chemin n'est jamais que la
perpétuation de l'ancien pour preuve les
équipes qu'il a acquis et la mise en
place à la fois monsieur castex mais
aussi les ministres il a fait enlever
les incompétents notoires mais c'est
castaner madame belloubet m'aide à me
pénicaud mais il a maintenu les
idéologues monsieur le maire monsieur
darmanin monsieur blanc caire et les
autres autrement dit ceux là vont avoir
pour mission d'aller au bout de la tâche
de libéralisation de l'état qui va se
faire sur le dos des français et c'est
une stratégie du choc que monsieur
macron veut mettre en place qu'il va
arroser et saupoudrée d'une part de
retour à l'ordre et ce faisant il va
vouloir capter l'électorat de la droite
et rejouer le match de 2010 est face à
face à madame le pen
sauf que on voit bien que tout cela
n'est jamais que de la politique fiction
le monde réel n'est pas celui là vous
aurez noté les enquêtes d'opinion qui
nous disent laon ce mois de juin et de
juillet que les intentions de vote des
françaises et des français pour 2022
sont exactement les mêmes que celles qui
étaient donnés en octobre dernier
autrement dit avant la réforme des
retraites par exemple avant la crise du
cornât virus et ses enquêtes n'ont pas
du tout bougé de même que le résultat
des municipales a finalement laissé un
équilibre entre les grands blocs comme
nous l'avions connu en 2014
ce que je veux dire c'est que la
situation actuelle la réalité du pays
la réalité de notre quotidien n'a pas
aujourd'hui encore infuser sur la scène
politique parce que celle ci est
complètement verrouillé mais cela ne
pourra pas aller jusqu'en 2022 est
forcément 2022 va être le moment d'un
basculement nous ne rejoueront pas en
le match de 2010 est tout simplement
parce que les françaises et les français
ont dit à l'occasion du premier et
surtout du second tour des municipales
qui ne voulait plus participer à cette
mascarade avec toutes celles et tous
ceux qui corsètent est la vie
démocratique et finalement qui capte le
pouvoir à notre détriment
merci beaucoup françois copt cas d'avoir
réagi sur votre antenne je rappelle que
vous êtes essayiste la cérémonie donc du
et qui a pris fin il ya quelques
instants emmanuel macron qui est encore
là dans les tribunes qui ne va pas
tarder d'ailleurs voit la sécu c'est
pour donner son interview du 14 juillet
un exercice qu'il avait annulé et
finalement cette année il va se prêter
au jeu le président de la république en
répondant aux questions des journalistes
voilà de nombreuses questions qui
attendent le président de la république
à deux ans de la fin de son mandat qui
va être donc essayer de relancer son
quinquennat on va justement continuer à
parler
de cette cérémonie exceptionnelle hors
norme avec notre invité nous sommes en
ligne avec virginie martin politologue
virginie martin bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on a vu un les
personnes mobilisées durant est la crise
sanitaire était à l'honneur aujourd'hui
pour cette cérémonie du 14 juillet
qu'elle portait peut-on accorder à cet
hommage exceptionnel
écoutez il ya de toute façon une
instrumentalisation toujours politique
bien sûr de ce genre dommage puisque là
on a vu c'est une séquence émotion très
forte
et finalement on le sait très bien en
communication politique une fois qu'on
joue la carte de l'émotion
vous comprenez bien que le cérébral se
met sur postes et on ne va plus osé
critiquer donc finalement l'émotion sert
évidemment à une baisse de la vigilance
politique d'une part et aussi finalement
à travailler l'unité potentiel putatif
d'un pays en termes de communication ça
marche toujours très bien et puis
évidemment derrière on voit bien qu'à un
grand contraste entre ce très bel
hommage si je puis dire et la réalité
des hôpitaux et la réalité de ce qui se
passe sur le terrain
donc c'est toujours un petit peu
évidemment au mieux à de force et
l'image et forcé le trait mais c'est
utile en termes de communication
politique bien entendu est-ce que voilà
la communication politique sera
également au coeur de cette interview
qui aura lieu en mi journée
que va chercher à faire le chef de
l'état durant sept ans cet endroit de
serre votre avis un peu ce qu'il fait
depuis ce matin c'est à dire créer de
l'unité essayer justement de d'enjamber
on définitive les problèmes c'est à dire
à la fois ou plutôt ses échecs c'est à
dire par exemple les municipales ne lui
ont pas été favorables c'est comme si
elle n'avait pas existé il les a très
très vite en jambes et là aujourd'hui on
a un grand contraste on à l'ordre on à
l'autorité on a des choses très bien
réglée alors que pendant justement la
crise du coc vide il ya eu le désordre
les errances les hésitations ça a été
véritablement très conflictuelle et là
tout d'un coup il ne se passe plus rien
on gomme donc le président république
aime beaucoup à enjamber comme ça les
problèmes et ce qui ne lui est pas
finalement favorable d'autant plus qu'
il ya eu évidemment là le triple
avantage du triple anniversaire de
gaulle donc de sa mort de sa naissance
et du 18 juin 40
donc là aussi emmanuel macron à chercher
encore à retrouver de la verticalité et
ne jamais surtout perdre cette
verticalité jupitérienne qui lui tient
tant à coeur
maintenant sur le discours de tout à
l'heure on va enfin peut-être avoir un
discours de cadrage puisqu'on voit bien
que les nouveaux ministres et notamment
le premier ministre le nouveau premier
ministre l'a finalement s'agite un peu
dans le pays par tous en guyane et c'est
parce que finalement il n'a pas eu le
droit de prononcer son discours de
politique générale puisque le président
de la république doit parler en premier
donc c'est aujourd'hui qu'il va parler
il est temps il est temps de raconter ce
nouveau chemin 1
mais ce nouveau chemin aussi contraste
et va sûrement contrasté avec ce qu'on
voit ce matin et la réalité de toute
façon du pays à la fois économique
sociale en termes d'unités et en termes
de santé aussi puisque le co vide
revient visiblement emmanuel macron or
nous on l'a dit avec un exercice de
communication dont il ne voulait plus
entendre parler ce une manière pour lui
de reprendre les choses en main c'est
une manière surtout de se poser on est
rouge de guerre finalement
aujourd'hui évidemment c'est tout à
propos puisque rappelez vous il avait
dit le la lutte contre le coronavirus
c'est une guerre c'est une guerre est là
aujourd'hui il se pose en héros comme si
nous avions finalement signé une
armistice avec le co vite ce qui n'est
évidemment pas le cas donc c'est un peu
paradoxal et avec sur son anglais un peu
approximatif qui dit aussi à un des
anglophones de la salle à will be there
are il dit ah oui by her d'ailleurs mais
bon passons
mais est donc ça fait un peu un
terminator comme ça et est un peu héros
de guerre justement est tout droit tirée
d'un film hollywoodien
donc c'est toujours cette place qui lui
tient à coeur et on voit bien finalement
ça lui va très bien de remettre à
l'honneur ce discours et 7
cette interview du 14 juillet je pense
que c'était plutôt un effet de volonté
de démocratie de 2,2 d'empathie avec le
peuple qui ne lui a filé finalement pas
je trouve qu'il est mieux qu'ils soient
dans son exercice finalement d'autorité
jupitérienne et qu'il dise qu'il est
avec cette interview du 14 juillet ça me
paraît beaucoup plus raccord avec le
personnage et l'exercice de son pouvoir
est ce que le chef de l'état essaie de
se donner une stature de vendetta
justement avec voilà cet hommage aussi
qui a été rendu aujourd'hui à la figure
historique du général de gaulle il
essaye de reprendre un petit peu c'est
pas oui j'en parlais tout à l'heure il a
la chance encore une fois les planètes
sont très bien alignées et donc
finalement ce triple hommage donc
aujourd'hui au général de gaulle donc de
sa mort de sa naissance et du 18 juin 40
sont très importants parce que
finalement sans le dire dans les
imageries et la symbolique vivien le
monde ils arrivent à se mettre dans les
pas alors dans les représentations vous
voyez inconscient aucun de nos cerveaux
et de nos esprits tout ça finira de
toute façon peu ou prou par plus ou
moins collé ça c'est très important
d'une part et ça permet aussi de se
poser au dessus de l'histoire ou deux au
delà de l'histoire du quotidien au delà
des gilet jaune
là des conflits au delà du problème des
retraites au delà du coc vie au delà de
tout tout d'un coup on rend dans la
grande histoire dans l'histoire
gaullienne gaulliste et donc les manuels
macron lui rend hommage
ceci dit c'est normal mais on voit bien
que ça n'arrive pas de n'importe quand
aussi et c'est une occasion aussi de dés
pour l'utiliser ce qu'il se passe en
france aujourd'hui dépolitiser pour
remettre la grande histoire d'un côté
avec de gaulle l'émotion avec les
soignants de l'autre on dépolitise le
débat le quotidien des français qui
risque d'être un petit peu perturbé les
prochains jours des manifestations
encore avec le personnel hospitalier qui
va manifester cet après midi qui n'est
pas totalement convaincu par le ségur de
la santé la réforme des retraites qui va
être un dossier important du
gouvernement castex sûrement à la
rentrée il reste deux ans à emmanuel
macron à la tête du pays
quelles vont être les défis à relever
selon vous les défis je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il ait envie d affronter parce que
les vrais des filles c'est retrouver
l'unité du pays
l'unité du pays est véritablement dans
un état pitoyable depuis trois ans et
c'est ça le vrai défi mais je ne suis
pas sûr que ce ça se soit finalement ce
plat qui importe vraiment emmanuel
macron en tout cas il n'en montre pas
les signes on a plutôt l'impression
qu'il fait un peut être un calcul plus
politicien de dire finalement dans ce
pays aujourd'hui au regard du nombre de
votants
il suffit d'avoir 15 20 23 % de gens qui
votent pour vous au premier tour à la
présidentielle
et ça passe et ça passe donc finalement
on a plutôt l'impression qui vient
câline et cajolé rassurer ses 20%
d'électeurs putatif qui pourrait lui
apporter son soutien leur soutien par
don dès le premier tour et là square
aujourd'hui ce sont des électeurs plus
conservateurs ce sont des électeurs de
droite sont des électeurs qui se disent
libéraux du point de vue économique
et là on voit bien beaucoup plus
servent acteurs du point de vue sociétal
alors quelle manière la cour se disait
ouvert du point de vue sociétal
on voit bien aujourd'hui avec les
nominations de dupond moretti d'un côté
de dharmanand de l'autre on voit bien
qu'il n'ya pas grand-chose de libéral
sur les sur les idées des moeurs puisque
évidemment ça véhicule au contraire
sexisme patriarcat donc des choses très
classique très conservatrice et très un
peu old school si je puis dire mais ça
permet de gagner l'électorat qui votent
et ça c'est très important celui des
personnes âgées celui des gens de droite
puis des gens très inclus dans la
société qui sont peu abstentionnistes
donc normalement
la tâche du président république devrait
peut-être retrouver l'unité offert
l'unité dans la nation mais il me semble
et je crains qu'il s'intéresse plutôt à
la présidentielle à venir et donc à des
tactiques plus politiciennes et de
communication politique
merci beaucoup mais je n'ai martin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue
nous sommes toujours en édition spéciale
vous avez pu suivre en direct cette
cérémonie du 14 juillet une cérémonie
exceptionnelle
voilà restreinte qui sait
déroulée place de la concorde on va
retrouver estelle farges estelle le
défilé est terminée un mini défilé en
raison de la crise salutaire mais le
programme d' emmanuel macron est encore
très chargé
oui exactement d'euros après une
cérémonie inédite vous l'avais dit en
format réduit emmanuel macron va renouer
avec le traditionnel entretien télévisé
à l'occasion du 14 juillet le chef de
l'état qui va préciser son cap pour les
deux dernières années de son quinquennat
il est attendu au tournant à emmanuel
macron dans un contexte de crise
sanitaire et économique sans précédent
emmanuel macron qui devra préciser
notamment son plan de relance économique
et de soutien à l'emploi sans oublier
les mesures pour l'environnement a
annoncé lors de la convention à
citoyenne pour le climat autre dossier
sensible sur lequel le chef de l'état ce
vrai c'est devrait s'exprimer est les
retraites et la réforme que le
gouvernement souhaite remettre en route
il ya aussi la question des soignants et
puisque vous le savez le ségur de la
santé s'est achevé il y a quelques jours
avec un accord sur des revalorisations
salariales mais certains syndicats de
soignants ont déjà exprimé leur
mécontentement ils appellent à
manifester cet après midi avec un départ
à 14 heures place de la république
merci beaucoup et c'est el farj apporte
toutes ces précisions et on va quitter
paris pour se rendre à nice où
aujourd'hui on célèbre aussi un hommage
en comité restreint car il y a quatre
ans jour pour jour un attentat meurtrier
a secoué la ville un attentat qui a
coûté la vie à 86 personnes une
cérémonie de recueillement s'est tenue
ce matin les seules les familles des
victimes étaient autorisés à y
participer
dans la journée les niçois pourront se
recueillir autour du mémorial installé
dans le jardin de la villa masséna je
vous propose d'écouter le témoignage de
christine qui a perdu son père lors de
ce drame un sujet signé isabelle
ferrières et une ligue en cash
quatre ans après christine est toujours
sous le choc
[Musique]
le 14 juillet 2016 elle se trouvait sur
la promenade des anglais à nice avec son
époux didier on a marché un petit peu et
là on a senti quelques gouttes qui
tombaient avec un petit vent donc on a
décidé de rentrer on a fait demi tour et
c'est là qu'on a vu des gens courir dans
tous les sens et tout d'un coup j'ai vu
un policier municipal qui sortait son
arme pour pour viser le camion on a levé
le canon qu'à rêver se faire tirer
dessus
les parents de custine avait fini par
sortir plus car de leur côté si sa mère
claude a survécu son père est lui décédé
à 78 ans il a fallu du temps avant de le
retrouver à la suite du drame
jean-pierre avaient déjà été transportés
à l'hôpital là on a eu de nouveau
donner de nouveaux l'identité de mon
père nous a fait passer pas voir une
personne qui nous a dit que
effectivement il y avait toujours un
homme inconnu sans nom qui répondait pas
dans le coma et donc on l'a pas reconnu
tellement qu'il était défigurée c'est
grâce à un test adn que christine aura
finalement la confirmation qu'il s'agit
bien de son père grièvement blessé il
est décédé plus d'un mois après
l'attentât
avec le traumatisme de la mort d'un
parent ce sont aussi des images
terribles qui viennent hanter cette
famille en particulier sa mère
aujourd'hui âgée de 85 ans il lui est
toujours impossible de parler de cette
soirée
au départ c'était très compliqué quand
même parce qu'elle a été aussi renversé
et ses recrues
elle avait longtemps des cauchemars des
personnes la matière y avait sept
personnes à côté de moi qu'avec la tête
dans le caniveau la téte ans enfin avait
quand même des images assez fort qui
était difficile et donc en mettant tous
ensemble c'est vrai que c'est quand même
plus facile aussi de remonter la pente
remonter la pente mais ne pas oublier un
mémorial en hommage aux victimes de
l'attentât a justement été érigés par la
ville de nice sur la promenade des
anglais où s'est déroulé l'attentât le
nom des 86 victimes ya été gravé et
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de l'avoir suivi et prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité à 13 heures
en compagnie d'amis rabat la balle à
jean-pierre très bonne journée à tous
sur rtl
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion